just joining us now is a Republican
strategist former senior advisor John
McCain's 2008 presidential campaign
MSNBC political analyst and Woody
Harrelson look alike Steve Schmidt Steve
thanks for coming on happy 420 420 to
you John thank you very much important
day for both of us I know let me ask let
me ask this question this morning on
Morning Joe you are insistent emphatic
like no question in your mind Donald
Trump is going to get to 1237 buy it by
the end of the nominating causes june
eight we were to wake up Donald Trump
will be the nominee on the first ballot
what gives you that level of confidence
that you were just for sure it's going
to happen I think if you generously
apportion a couple of Western State wins
to Ted Cruz you look at northeastern
states you look ahead to California 170
+ delegates winner-take-all by
congressional district 20 point lead
very difficult for me to see any
scenario where he doesn't clear 1237 I
think the worst he does is he clears it
by 60 70 delegates I think he'll be
right up around 1300 when we wake up on
Junie eighth that having been said if
you took over the Cruz campaign tomorrow
what would you do there's not a lot they
can do look they've been trying to
narrow this to a two-person race from
the beginning and I think there was one
point where the great danger for Donald
Trump is that he would be in a position
having to fight in a to a race to his
ideological right but i think that
moment has passed and i think the
conservative litmus test such as it is
is not an ideological one it's a
strength test and Donald Trump has Trump
Ted Cruz on that on that test and so Ted
Cruz right now when he's tried to for so
long make this a two-person race comes
in third place in New York behind John
Kasich somebody that he's called for to
get out of the race because he's simply
a hindrance there's no rationality if I
were just a basic I'll give you your
two-person race buddy right I finished
exactly exactly right so I so I think
that Ted Cruz I think it was a really
bad night for him last night you know
and and so when you look at crews coming
into these northeastern states going to
lose more momentum next week you have a
real tough part of this real tough time
in this part of the country so is Mitt
Romney right that the fact that this the
three-person race the case
guys stayed in the crews had stayed in
that there's been a split in the
nevertrump world the anti-trump vote is
that part of why Donald Trump's gonna
get 1237 is that always I don't I don't
you know we talked about the nevertrump
movement I I don't from a from a
practical effect it doesn't seem to be
very potent to say the to say the least
and I understand that there's hashtags
and never Trump but there's not an
organized effort with any effectiveness
you know aimed at stopping them no one's
making the argument I mean the argument
makes no sense you people go i would say
never Trump well will you support Trump
as the Republican nominee I'm going to
support the nominee in my party both
cannot be true and it undermines the the
argument you know that and no one is
saying in public what people say
privately about Donald Trump and the
Republican establishment and leadership
and I think that speaks to why that
movement is so weak what are they saying
privately are they saying privately he's
unfit to be present in the United States
and they'll never vote for him he's
unfit psychologically he's unfit
temperamentally he's unfit ideologically
but no one is making that argument
publicly you you were you were reluctant
to say what you would do to take over
the Cruz campaign because he said there
wasn't much they could do if I give you
a hundred million bucks and say stop
Trump what would you spend it on what
message and how would you spend it you
try to stop him on temperament issues
you would go back and you will revisit
and look the most powerful political ad
in American history was the Daisy ad in
1964 against LBJ LBJ running against
Barry Goldwater I had using images of
the North Korean leader mushroom clouds
the instability of the world and trumpet
of late-night tweeting you know you'd
make a you make a temperament and
character attack and you'd remind people
that the President of the United States
is the most powerful person in the world
sits atop the National Command Authority
is commander-in-chief of the most potent
military in the world that possesses the
weapons to extinguish life on the planet
as we know it I'm asking a question just
about just today okay we woke up this
morning Donald Trump got a lot of praise
from a lot of people for his speech last
night different Donald Trump and one of
the things everyone sees Don was a
stupid
a small thing didn't say lyin Ted Cruz
said senator Cruz different right today
Donald Trump's out in Indiana called
lyin Ted Cruz of it by the middle of the
afternoon so how do i read that it's
that a sign that the newly imposed
discipline is not actually as effective
as we thought it was his Donald Trump's
is back to his old tricks what do we
make of that I think there's a
distinction between the speech you make
where a lot of the country is watching
in prime time you've just won an
election it's not a rally setting you're
talking about the next stage of the
campaign you're articulating a vision
why you should be the nominee why you
want to be President United States where
you're going to lead and he start to
transition into the general election
messaging you know Indiana is a contest
he's going to have to compete in and
he's going at Ted Cruz hard so I think
good said in the light of the day the
day after in a state as we get ready for
the next contest but the difference in
tone on an election night when were
weeks away from their steaks and water
and everything else up around the push
my biggest significance wouldn't you
worry a few one of the forces trying to
impose a presidential demeanor on Trump
from inside the campaign if you saw him
suddenly turn around and beat back the
old the old would you not be kind of
like oh my God he's back again I think I
think the issue is not the use of lying
Ted the issue is comportment can he
comport himself the right way at the at
the right times can he show the
appropriate dignity required of the
American head of state of less than 30
seconds if one of your other old bosses
Dick Cheney gave a big speech saying
Donald Trump should not be our nominee
with that hurt Trump's chances or not I
think at one moment in time it would
have hurt Trump's chances I think Dick
Cheney is a deeply respected figure
inside the conservative movement inside
the Republican Party but I think it's
very very late in the day for anybody to
go out and to make that argument look
Mitt Romney is a person inside the
Republican Party that has a lot of
affection has a lot of respect he went
out he gave a speech i think the effect
of that speech you know was not
particularly injurious to Donald Trump's
chances
steve schmidt